line in the past when he was 12 and uh  16 years old so we will talk to her to  him leading up to that big game  do you think magnus is now thinking  about that game  sitting here it's got to be on his mind  uh knowing mac  um  it looks like black is just  mouth-slipped under the rook  but if this rook is captured it's  stalemate has no legal move i love it i  love it  only you know only someone as  imaginative as david navarro would draw  in that way because there are other ways  and you know that that shows a bit of  beauty in it a bit of beauty so just uh  oh what a bit of humor interesting i  love it i love it and look at you  smiling i like that as well really good  oh magnus doesn't capture the rook  i mean navarro reminds me a lot of evan  trick some of his  mannerisms both on and off the board i  mean fantastic memory kind of almost  photographic memory  um creative  loves to fight  doesn't go for those quick draws doesn't  go for safe chess